si en ce moment tous les concerts et
événements populaires sont annulés
certains ont trouvé la parade pour
continuer à faire penser le monde sans
bouger de chez eux c'est le cas de david
guetta qui a choisi de vivre cette
période de confinement à miami en
floride
et c'est depuis sa résidence américaine
qu'il a décidé d'organiser samedi
dernier une grande soirée diffusée en
direct sur internet dans le monde entier
dans l'optique de récolter de l'argent à
destination de l'om est ce là feeding
south florida la feeding america et la
fondation hôpitaux de paris hôpitaux de
france 1,7 de près de deux heures en
direct de la terrasse de son immeuble
[Musique]
un mix david guetta a réalisé qu'ovide
oblige entièrement munis de gants en
plastique
live qui en plus de faire danser le
monde entier sur internet a aussi fait
danser ses voisins
pendant 1h40 l'un des dj les plus
populaires du monde à mixer ses tubes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais aussi les sons du moment que c'est
une chose
le tout comme toujours avec sa célèbre
signature les mains lever au total ce
show united atome a permis de récolter
six cent mille euros grâce à la
générosité des spectateurs des dons que
david guetta s'était engagé à doubler la
vie m'a beaucoup donné mais je n'ai
peut-être pas assez rendu alors j'ai eu
envie de monter ce projet pour récolter
des fonds pour différents organismes
français et américains pour ceux qui
veulent danser le live est toujours
disponible en intégralité sur le compte
youtube de david guetta c'est un gros
gros big up à david eugène qui est un
mec exceptionnel série d'après demain
tas d'habits c'est quoi demain on
essaiera de la paix dans l'édition david
guetta qu'est mon fils j'ai préféré
qu'émotif frères qu'eugène voilà et qui
est extrêmement symbolique est venu nous
voir plein de fois et j'adorais la
phrase qu'il a dite il a dit la ville
m'a beaucoup donné
franchement j'adore ce mec wigig moi
j'ai regardé franchement c'est à la paix
mais aussi c'était fantastique j'ai
trouvé toute son humanité
après il y avait les voisins qui dansait
on avait l'impression d'y être
et en fait ça redonne une humanité peut
pas la zone de concert pour l'impression
que imx pour vous et franchement c'était
génial et j'ai un problème rien tu me
dit david guetta chaud dans ce tumulte à
venise et à de la prison bien de la
personne c'est un truc tôt jeudi juste
le nom philippe david guetta sort du
dedans c'est par là ça a pris le savez
qu'on puisse moi mon cousin s'appelle
d'alice d'état il sait pas du tout même
le biais d'un médecin il est médecin il
s'appelle david guetta c'est à dire bien
d'avoir ce dernier mec quand ils doivent
arriver chez lui ça va c'est pour une
pneumonie
[Musique]
[Rires]
point d'étape elle présente david guetta
l'eia c'est à dire quand ils arrivent
ils voient la plaque qui disent mais
attends david guetta fera c'est pas
méchant ça t'es fou quoi aller ses
bottes déshabillez vous déshabillez vous
[Rires]